you were a high school speech champion
Yeah right it is that's something you're
proud of that I mean I think I have to
be I think it's one of those things
that's like you better actually act like
this is something that you're cool with
rather than like I think it's a good
thing it's a wonderful thing and I was
like too shy to audition for plays and
so the speeching was not debate it's not
like people pretending to be like
lincoln-douglas right or whatever
whatever I actually have no idea what
that is but yeah that's just too boring
for me to understand but but it's it's
like theater dorks who cut a play down
to ten minutes and do all of the
characters and then that turns into a
competition okay yeah so and you were a
champion
I was a champion were you a champion the
whole time like all the way through like
the end of your high school career well
sort of
except that like I was not I didn't I
wasn't like super popular in high school
I wanted to party I wanted a boyfriend
those things didn't happen to me and
then at the very end of high school like
I kind of got my window but I was
supposed to go to the national speech
team championship and it was like oh I
can either go to this speech team
championship and be alone or go to these
parties and maybe like French kiss
people world yes a baker's dozen but so
I was like I'm not I told my parents
like I'm not going to the national
championship and my dad got so mad at me
and was like you're letting the team
down and I in my one moment of teen rage
I mean I've had many teen rage moments
like in my late 20s but the only one
that happened in my teen you were not a
rebel no we're not rebellious but this
was your moment where you snapped that's
right and I was like - your dad yeah but
then here's what happened with your dad
my dad and then he looks at me my dad is
like do not be a [ __ ] unless you want
to see what a [ __ ] looks like and so he
stood in the doorway of my my childhood
dressing room and he went no Jen
[Applause]
[Music]
clear clearly neither one of you needed
to study debate who saw that coming yeah
that's right that's not what a dad
supposed to do I think in that situation
yeah sounds all right to me
[Laughter]